je travaillais à 7 heures du matin avec
votre bague qui a gonflé autour de fin à
votre doigt que les gonfle autour de
votre mag et vous nous appelez à 16h
c'est ça ou je vais vous mettre m la
relation qu'a médecin du samu un accord
de paris c'est ici au niveau de la plate
forme d'appels d'urgence que son reçu
tous les appels 18 112 17 de paris et de
la petite couronne
malgré le filtre une en place au niveau
de la plate forme d'appels vous avez
quand même des appels qui génère des
interventions abusive et sur les 500
grammes 2000 qu'on a réalisés en 2018
vous en avez une sur cinq cent mille qui
n'a nécessité aucun gestes de secourisme
de la part des des secours confère du
temps ça m'a pris peut-être valait 4 4
minutes 4 min 30
sur l'ensemble de la journée au nombre
d'appels comprend est une perte de temps
pour des douze appels importants
d'autres motifs qui justifient l'engin
dans bretons c'est rire mes côtés parce
que je ne serai pas tél à la maison je
ne peux pas les sauver les soupers vous
voulez que les pompiers viennent chez
vous pour transporter vos cartons et pas
des 400 v cc des saccades l'alimentation
l'eau dans les boucliers on n'est pas là
pour venir porter les affaires
lorsqu'on paie j'écoute oui bonjour je
suis aveugle vient de découvrir que mon
parcours
il est bon et noir n'ont pu venir c'est
pas de missions des pompiers je vous
mettre en relation avec edf monsieur les
pompiers de paris n'intervienne pour les
personnes coincées dans les ascenseurs
que lorsque ces derniers sont tombés à
fond un malaise si ils sont juste coincé
vous appelez le numéro de maintenance de
la société d'ascenseur est la personne
va venir vous ouvrir
les pompiers de paris on intervient pour
des fuites d'eau importante où il va y
avoir un risque sur accident électrique
ou autre c'est une fuite d'eau
domestique quand c'est une machine à
laver un évier avec un petit écoulement
un dégât des eaux du voisin il faut
appeler votre humble plombier tout
simplement toutes les personnes qui nous
appellent parce qu'elles sont laissés
claqué la porte de leur logement et qui
n'ont pas envie de payer un serrurier et
elle pense que les pompiers vont pouvoir
leur ouvrir la porte en prétextant par
exemple qu'elles ont laissé une
casserole sur le feu
ça ça consomme des moyens d'urgence qui
sont là pour sauver les vies pape
oeuvres des portes les appels abusifs ça
impacte le les personnels déjà dans un
premier temps qui eux partent sur
intervention car ça monopolise des
engins des hommes
alors c'est pas justifié pour eux c'est
des interventions en plus donc de la
fatigue en plus et en attendant ils ne
sont pas sur des interventions qui sont
justifiées notamment des feux ou des
détresses vitales où on a besoin de
faire un massage cardiaque nous en tant
qu'opérateur ces appels abusifs nous
prennent aussi également de l'énergie
parce qu'il faut rester concentré sur
chaque appel expliqué calmement aux
requérants que ça ne fait pas partie des
missions de pompiers que certains appels
abusifs et ce qui ne doit pas arriver
mais ce qui peut arriver c'est de passer
à côté d'un appel
l'appel suivant qui peut être un appel
d'urgence vitale c'est à dire un appel
pour un massage cardiaque pour un feu
avec éventuellement des victimes ou un
accident grave de la circulation